según joe biden en sus primeros 100 días
de gobierno ha cumplido con 35 de las 61
promesas de campaña que anunció antes de
llegar a la casa blanca muchas de estas
propuestas cumplidas han tenido que ver
precisamente con ponerle fin a la
pandemia y con mejorar rescatar la
economía sobre todo para los
estadounidenses más afectados
precisamente el éxito parcial en pues
abordar la pandemia y mejorar la
economía de los estadounidenses le ha
dado al presidente joe biden una
aceptación de cerca del 55 por ciento de
los estadounidenses así lo están
indicando el promedio de las últimas
seis encuestas nacionales recordemos que
el discurso de esta noche será a las
nueve de la noche hora de washington y
serán entonces estarán ahí la plenaria
del congreso
la cámara de representantes del senado y
de la cámara ahora cree estado al cual
será la principal propuesta que expondrá
hoy ante el país en la plenaria del
congreso y cuáles están todavía sin
aprobarse
y esta noche será la primera vez que joe
biden me hable en frente al congreso
desde que llegó a la casa blanca y la
propuesta principal será un plan
familiar un plan familiar estimado en
1,8 billones de dólares precisamente
para tratar de ayudarle a los
estadounidenses a las familias más
afectadas durante la pandemia este plan
incluye entre muchas otras cosas pues
más dinero para la educación un aumento
en el gasto para el cuidado de niños
menores de edad y también exenciones de
impuestos precisamente a estas familias
más afectadas además pues hay que
resaltar que está por aprobarse en el
congreso también el plan de
infraestructura el plan infraestructura
que además también incluye varios temas
climáticos un plan que es cercano a los
2 billones de dólares y pues que traía
traería mucho más gasto para renovar las
vías para renovar los puertos las vías
férreas los aeropuertos también para
mejorar el sistema de acuerdo
proveer mejor agua que es uno de los
temas que yo bailén también prometió en
campaña estás este dinero saldrá de los
estadounidenses más ricos y ahí es
cuando los republicanos que tienen la
mayoría la mitad del senado pueden poner
pues trabas en estos proyectos porque lo
que dice yo bailé es que la mayoría de
esta plata para financiar tanto el plan
de las familias como el plan de
infraestructura va a venir de más
aumentos para los ricos algo que sé que
no le gusta a los republicanos y pues
que podría generar pues trabas en la
aprobación final de estos proyectos
hacia cristóbal gracias por toda la
información